so the first time you and I met was uh
at the TV show yeah oh good memory yes
it was yeah you had you had to do with
those alligators in it in a pool that
sounds right yeah
a kiddie pool full of alligators and got
my butt cheek bitten by a little bit
rehearsal it didn't happen and everyone
was freaking out and you said trust me
it'll happen
but I remember the backstage was going
what if what if they don't what if they
don't bite his butt we have no bit and
then you came in you're like dude
they're gonna buy my bags fine yeah
was Mel Gibson there that day it wasn't
yeah yeah and a kilt all right and I
came out like yeah I did I came out in a
kilt with the with that turned into
pants it was like a prop and then I had
these stupid little legs so I had to
Kilt and then I went I made this soap
for guys like me and it matched you know
the thing and then yeah and then it was
you me and Mel Gibson yeah on a lineup
now was that at the point when you were
like
bodybuilder man no I don't think so I'm
actually not if you see me in person I
look normal size people always think I'm
bigger than it right right TV has 10
pounds kind of thing right that's why I
just wanted to be in porn
thank you yeah I remember like you you
aren't as big as you once were is that
fair to say yeah yeah yeah
um but uh but yeah that that was great
and then there was another time we hung
out in Vegas we got this iconic photo
yes it's great uh it's it Booth had some
like big crazy nightclub felt like we
were at a rave yeah it probably was a
rave yeah and if we were in this big
booze
you me Chris Angel Angel flavorful
Flavor Flav
and uh Tom Green yeah the five of us and
then that photo it's a great shot it's a
really great picture how the [ __ ] did
that happen how do you guys get together
in that shot it was such a great shot
and like man did people poop on it
was like they're like yeah Flavor Flav
Chris Angel Carrot Top Tom Green and
Stevo if that's not the Mount Rushmore
I loved it it was such a fun that was a
fun game yeah it was fun it was just a
eclectic Gathering yeah they're also
nice flavor just came to my show a
couple weeks ago he's always been it
flavors he's like the one for president
you know when when he when he comes to
show when I announce him I said
different flavor flaves here they the
crown goes ape [ __ ] yeah I mean and then
I'm like you know back to me [ __ ]
Jesus but it's crazy yeah I got him on a
plane one time I was running literally
running San Francisco Airport to my gate
and I get to the gate and this guy's
like
just
you know I'm not drunk man you gotta let
me on this [ __ ] plane I'm not Dr I'm
not drunk and I look back and it's you
know see the clock has got to be the
flavor flavor one of the 33 flavors and
I look and I said I said flavor
he looks over he's like and I had never
met him he says carrots up I said what's
wrong why won't they let you in the
plane the lady's like excuse me sir he's
he's intoxicating he can't get on the
plane I said he's not he's not he's not
intoxicated he's Flavor Flav
and all I remember saying that and she
said sorry I said he's that's him that's
who he is he's not drunk I promise he's
I'll I'll test for it so I said give me
your hand I walked him on the plane let
him go on and same thing to this day he
always says man you [ __ ] saved my
life man got me in that plane and he got
on the plane I mean the place was the
plane went nuts I mean he walked in the
plane
yeah halftime at Super Bowl crazy yeah
he's the sweetest we uh we we had him on
the podcast and um he exchanged numbers
that day and he'll just call to check on
me oh that's nice he's just I will never
do that
yeah what I thought was fascinating
about Flavor Flav was he is uh he went
to school for culinary so he he can cook
that's crazy and I would never have
thought that he had a chicken place here
for a while yeah he did yeah I don't
know he did and and man when we went to
go to the park because we don't always
do it on this tour bus normally it's in
uh like a a little Sprinter van type
thing yeah I saw that on the thing yeah
yeah we'll drive it over to wherever
people want to meet up for Flavor Flav
it was uh this insane mansion in Bel Air
I'm like
flavor flavor you live in this
this day and uh yeah he's he's doing
very well for himself it's great it's
called Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on Amazon and
type in Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and Order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
Amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on Amazon and buy
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude